pour mon anniversaire j'ai reçu plein de
vidéos parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
me disent 'voilà série dont on a envie
que tu nous fasses des trucs pour ton
anniversaire que tu me fasses des
régalade comme on dit voilà et y en a
une qui m'a beaucoup touché c'est celle
de camille sée mère de famille regardez
coco série lh je m'appelle camille je
t'envoie cette petite vidéo pour te
parler monfils simon
si will à 6 ans et ça fait un an et demi
qu'il se bat contre la leucémie et nous
prouve chaque jour qu'il est très
courageux et très fort c'est supporter
des soins qui seront très douloureux et
en tant que maman j'aimerais lui faire
plaisir six mois il a une passion depuis
un an et demi qu'il aide beaucoup dans
le combat contre la maladie c'est le
foot et il est fan du psg un fan
inconditionnel du psg et bien voilà je
fais appel à toi pour que tu puisse
m'aider à réaliser un de ses rêves
assister à un match de ligue des
champions voilà je te fais confiance
merci sinon il ya quelques jours on a
contacté famille donc la maman et je
vais demander de venir dans les
coulisses de l'émission pour faire une
surprise à simon alors je vais demander
à la famille de venir en plateau et à
tout le monde de faire le silence
ils vont en irak simon et on a une
petite surprise pour lui c'est parti
[Musique]
babacan merci merci merci mais ça va mon
chéri bonjour ça va bien ça va prend
t-il merci c'est papa merci à thierry
comment tu t'appelles
alors on a eu tous nous en raconter
l'histoire de simon et qui est
magnifique ça va du shérif alors dire
mon cher parce que repart et qu'on ne
voit pas lorsque je ferai tout ce que je
te met là que ce côté mais de là à ce
que tu es bien là et bien là ça va et ça
va t'aider tu me dis si tu as un
problème tu me dis alors s'ils vont ou
des fans du pg ouais c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment voilà c'est passé paper facile
pour vous je voulais absolument vous
soyez la sorte ce que votre vidéo nous a
beaucoup touchés si gentil et je sais
que tout elle bat le psg a toujours
préféré payer
neymar la marque et hier encore j'étais
content tu vas voir des matchs du pg
souvent pour tout le temps tu as déjà vu
un match de ligue des champions du pg
jamais il est champion on aimerait bien
y aller alors je vous le dis j'ai pas du
tout prévu de cadeaux donc ce que je
vais essayer de l'avoir en direct
j'aimerais te faire inviter à tous les
matches de ligue des champions paris 5
jan alors je vous dis c'est on le fait
en direct
je vais essayer sinon je le prendrais
sur moi d'appeler le président du paris
saint germain
non le prince nasser j'ai essayé de
l'appeler voilà lui demander il n'est
pas du tout content on jure que c'est
vrai on dirait que je l'appelle donc
j'appelle directement sur son portable
je vais appeler nasser je lui ai demandé
si je vais au téléphone il est obligé
dire où je vois mal le gars dire non
surtout qu'il est très sympa alors je
vais d'après ok je sais pas ce qui va me
dire va peut-être me dire qui êtes vous
je l'appelle tout de suite
j'appelle le président du paris st jean
inquiète alors on joue des numéros dans
si l'on prolonge thomas guingamp au
roudourou je suis très bien là bas
montiel
on a les mêmes j'appelle la série à voir
sinon perica je vous laisserai un
message ordina regard des missions de
juillet c'est un message public aimera
pendant l'émission et je lui ai laissé
un message à laisser passer et je veux
lui laisser un message
oui mais j'ai pas encore parlé alors
attends ils vont remettre
oui nasser c'est cyril hanouna je
voulais t'embrasser déjà te dire bravo
pour la victoire d'hier et je me suis
permis
vu notre amitié d'inviter une famille
pour tous les matches de ligue des
champions donc voilà je voulais juste
prévenir en série voilà on tu sais que
je t'aime fort je t'embrasse très fort
voilà donc c'est pour moi je m'en occupe
je connais ta générosité et je suis sûr
que ça va être bon et voilà je voulais
te dire que je t'aime fort et voilà donc
sinon tu peux lui dire merci merci voilà
donc c'est fait
les chéris j'ai un message du paris
saint germain
non je vous jure que c'est vrai direct
oui voilà il me dit je te rappelle voilà
par un mandataire et je pense que ça va
être
je pense que ça va être bon donc mon
chéri tu vas aller voir tous les matches
de ligue des champions
mon chéri est ce que je peux te demande
un petit service est ce que je pourrais
venir quand même au moins une fois
comment il va pas illégal
merci je vous fais bien sûr les filles
ont les enfants comment tu t'appelles ma
chérie ça remet à charlotte
bien sûr ça pour six mois charlotte tous
les cadeaux c'est pour vous
[Applaudissements]